got nothing for the intro so I thought I
just got to shoot my webbing they don't
actually have you really sweeter bad web
shooters the amazing spider-man do so in
the amazing spider-man 2 Peter Parker
has been spider-man for a while he's
really living it up and I really love
Andrew Garfield as spider-man Tim is
spider-man / Peter Parker is the
quintessential spider-man for the big
screen I'll defend that til I die just
in his attitude and persona you can tell
Andrew Garfield is not nineteen years
old in this movie or watch it you're
like I feel like you're like thirty dude
but just in his attitude and his [ __ ]
talk he's very spider-man I love seeing
that so now Jamie Foxx becomes electro
and in the trailers we were like we're
gonna get like three villains in this
movie they're technically are but there
are not three villains in this movie
really we see it on the banner three
villains I'm like um this movie's gonna
be crowded as [ __ ] and it kind of is but
it's not really because of the villains
rhinos in it kind of not really he just
dude he takes down in about two and a
half minutes having Rhino on the banners
it's kind of like having those dudes at
the beginning of the original Tim Burton
Batman you know the guys like a man
Johnny gobs got ripped it took a walk
off a roof awright no big loss having
Rhino on the banners for the amazing
spider-man 2 is like having those guys
on the banner for Batman he just doesn't
make sense so did yes slash that now
we're down to two villain electro via
he's the main villain the other one
isn't in it much so really it's like one
and a half villains in the movie electro
was really cool Jamie Foxx was good as
Elektra I love the way electro looks
these skins all see-through and blue and
electrical I was looking animals like I
feel like I can see through your skin
that's awesome I love things that just
look unique and original and interesting
and that was very cool speaking of
things that look cool this movie looks
really cool
spider-man's doing his spider-man ish
that is my favorite part of the movies
when you're watching he's just doing the
spider-man his stuff swinging around
even when he's free-falling he's
dropping from God knows how he got that
high just suits rippling like he's
really doing a freefall but ultimately
it is a movie about Peter Parker more
than spider-man and that didn't
necessarily bother me in this movie but
there were moments where I was like this
movie's striking on when I first heard
this movie's gonna have three villains I
was like it better be long enough and I
found that this movie is two hours
twenty minutes long I was like okay it's
long enough for three villains I guess I
still going to feel crowded but it's
long enough but there are not three
villains that share equal time in the
movie it really is one sin
role villain and that's 2 hours and 20
minutes of that which could work but
this movie just didn't work as well as I
wanted it to work for that most of the
movie revolves around Peter Parker Gwen
Stacy's will they won't they are they
are they not love thing that they have
going on which is fine I imagine a
Spider Man he's gonna have a complicated
love life but I feel like that could
have been condensed like example at the
end of the Amazing Spiderman it ends off
he's like Gwen I can't date you and then
it ends with him hinting that they could
maybe in the beginning of this movie
they're dating again and then he breaks
it off and then it's just his
back-and-forth thing I feel like he
could have had him break it off at the
end of the Amazing Spiderman one and
then when he's struggling with it
halfway through this movie have him date
her again and then have that be that
this on-again off-again thing just
really I was like do it or do not do it
love complication is fine in movies but
it gets old fast
there are a couple very touching moments
where you're like okay I guess that's
why people date and it feeds into the
overall thing I'm just saying it went on
for too long he and Harry Osborn have
their friendship it starts getting a bit
complicated and there's friction there
and you're like I see where this is
going and then there's a lecture he has
to deal with and then his love life he
has to deal with and then that thing
with his parents he has to deal with you
know that thing works like ooh your
parents have a secret that they cut most
of it out of the amazing spider-man one
but they touch on it in this movie and
then they resolve it and ultimately I
was like yo Errol his parents in the
comic book do have a story arc to them
it's not the same as they did in this
movie but they do have a story but they
resolve it in this movie and by the end
you're like okay so the whole thing with
his parents was to learn one thing one
thing that we already knew from the last
movie
Oscorp bad all right so there are a
couple other things that you learn also
but all in all so Peter Parker can find
resolution with his parents not being
there I just don't know why that had to
be in the movie it's just another
storyline this movie has to have in it
and that's what makes it feel crowded
it's not the villains
I saw the [ __ ] he has to do we just
focus the movie up by the end of this
movie there is another villain I'm gonna
give you I'm gonna use a comparison you
don't want to hear me use but I'm going
to use it because it's the best
comparison there is and I swear to you
venom in spider-man 3 had more screen
time than the villain at the end of this
movie hat and the shoehorn him in here
to set up for the sinister six thing
that they want to do with the other
movies I get that I'm just saying that
was the straw right there I was like
alright this movie's basically set up
for the next movie I know it feels like
I'm really bitching about this movie but
these are the things I need to address I
will say this movie has really deep
contrast what I mean by that is for
every scene that I loved and I will use
the term loved either scenes that I
loved in this movie I'm watching
I love that that is great that's
emotional they're killing it there's
another scene or thing or execution or
concept that I hated I was like that's
sloppy that's stupid why did they do it
that way in the end the amazing
spider-man 2 is fun it's a fun movie it
wasn't as good as I wanted it to be I
wanted this to be like movie idea I
wanted this to be the quintessential
spider-man experience Andrew Garfield's
greatest Peter Parker slash spider-man
Gwen Stacy's great they're great
together dane dehaan is great as Harry
Osborn there is a part near the end of
this movie it is my favorite part of the
movies I'm one of those things that
makes the movie for me the movie was
exciting it looked great all the cool
spider-man ish things you're gonna like
the cool spider manage things I will say
the amazing spider-man 2 is a good time
no alcohol required I'll do a spoiler
video where I touch more on the things I
liked and did not like I can't do that
yet but time in time this is the amazing
spider-man 2 have you seen it what did
you think about it and did you like it
more than the amazing spider-man 1 or do
you like one more than two whatever you
think I meant below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more